c'est tout
après l'émotion du livre l'émotion de la
rencontre amélie nothomb écrit un livre
par an depuis 1992 des romans toujours
très attendu par ses fans
cette vendéenne fait ses études à
l'université versailles saint quentin
elle attendait de rencontrer son auteur
préféré depuis longtemps pour l'occasion
elle lui a même écrit une lettre
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
touchant elle prend le temps de
comprendre de nous appeler par nos
prénoms ça se voit que c'est pas du
dessous mécanique
c'est vraiment une très belle personne
qui suit de très beaux livres donc pour
tous ceux qui la connaissent pas il faut
connaître mais les notes sont tous
apprécient son univers original et son
écriture soignée ils étaient nombreux à
patienter pour une dédicace et quelques
minutes des changes avec l'auteur
tout d'abord c'est parfaitement écrit
une fois qu'il maîtrise parfaitement la
langue française a pas fait des études
de file de loger pour rien et puis c'est
un pur bonheur
elle est super elle est adorable et très
très proches visiblement de ses lecteurs
et c'est très agréable
une rencontre tout aussi apprécié de
l'autre côté de la table
amélie nothomb n'était pas revenu à
saint quentin en yvelines depuis trois
ans elle ya trouvé un accueil très
chaleureux
vous savez quand on écrit et quand on
écrit au degré où j'écris on est
terriblement seul forcément et on ne
sait pas si ce qu'on écrit à un sens et
on sait encore moins qui se cachent de
l'autre côté du papier alors le moment
où on découvre c'est le moment de vérité
maintenant c'est vraiment on découvre
qu'ils se cachent de l'autre côté du
papier croyez moi c'est bouleversant son
dernier roman les prénoms dépit scène
est sorti le 22 août dernier et s'est
classé directement en tête des ventes de
la rentrée littéraire